в п'ятницю минулу виступав тут
прем'єр-міністр який пафосно заявив що 4
40 млрд грн направлено було на
безпілотники і закуплено 200 000
безпілотників можна задати запитання А
де вони чому сьогодні підвдіївкою 110
бригада без безпілотників чому сьогодні
під бахмутом 10та бригада без
безпілотників чому сьогодні на
Донецькому запоріжському херсонському
напрямках носять волонтери бпл
тепловізори і іншу техніку і зараз вашим
голосуванням колеги буде створено
наступне Кошти які сплачують військові
як свій податок заберуть в якийсь
спецфонд де Їх бутьь абсолютно
безконтрольно невідомо на що витрачати а
далі будуть продовжувати ті самі
волонтери возити завозити обладнувати
підрозділи військові бригади і
батальйони всцим необхідним Це
ненормально і тому наша позиція наступна
очевидно що податок маєте виключно на
потреби військових ми пропонуємо щоби в
цьому проекті бюджету
70% податку на доходу фізичних осіб які
спрачують військові залишалися саме в
військових підрозділах але щоби їх
передавав туди саме органи місцевого
самоврядування за запитами цих
підрозділів а 30% Щоб ішли на ремонт
частин постійної дислокації на житло для
військових на лікування для військових
на бомбосхо
згадайте Скільки ви кричали про те що з
укриттями в нас не все гаразд в Україні
так жодного укриття не створено і зараз
ви забираєте ці кошти у місцевого
самоврядування І абсолютно праві колеги
які говорять що отак от уже жовтень у
нас закінчується А ви цим законом
вводите в дію нові норми з Жовтня
нинішнього року це ненормально Такого не
буває в жодному бюджетному році наша
пропозиція цей законопроект направити на
повторне другечи знайти компроміс Ну і
останнє ви знаєте що Кошти які ви зараз
здаєте в оцей фонд 200 млрд вони йдуть
навіть на Міністерство оборони А на
держзв'язок фонд держзв'язку який не є
розпорядником бюджетних коштів який
навіть не може їх офіційно витрачати і
все це створює купу проблем лобійських
корупційних і інше ми пропонуємо цей
закон не голосувати